flag loss having family here I was also
having a lot this week Monday today was
quite productive checking the news
flexbox one of the sources that it's
really for the commanding yes can I use
I always come back to the stage for a
little chat if you know the feature is
already supported and I always say no
new issues mentioned and see which
versions are supported to which extent
work where there are some problems like
partial support due to the large amount
of bugs or who only supporting a
dependency tax and what's great about
this page can i use to come yes that you
also have resources suggested and here
you can find a lot of useful links one
of the links that i found here just fine
researching the page who's this one
which is the Hedra / about phone flex
packs this is this one it's a it's a git
repository about flexbox issues and
press browsers workarounds for them they
are very useful resource and denying the
paper that use very often the CSS are
the straights and SPSS tricks on the
phone and only stage those I can be type
of left foot it's going to a lot of
energy that can help you
that how it works we have also got a
perfect simplex goals because yes
because of this limited browser support
still you have to use of the graphic sir
prepare from the con here in this page
and you see assessments you can learn a
lot it's like a second if your second
type of information additional fee to
the main house
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
living in Spain you notice how various
this land and this you know well there
so you have the juxtaposition of
something that is really expensive with
something that it's really cheap and
with people who don't have money to live
coding nowadays it can be learned for
free that's why i love initiated such as
open source because everybody can use it
it's for free so what you need to pay
attention to and what she needs to pay
with it's your your time a majority of
other branch is in order to learn
something that you have to take coding
it's a bit different so to learn coding
or to learn design sure you can't go to
the school you can go to the University
you can pay for the courses you can pay
for boot camps for tutorials and I also
use partially resources but the UM toes
that cause of premature reals so saying
that you don't have money and you want
to learn to code is not an excuse but
you need to invest is your time and your
willingness to learn and be inconsistent
and you know coming back to code coming
back to new tutorials looking for the
sources reading a lot watching
subscribing being you know inquisitive
and being simply curious when you see a
great blog post look what else do they
write and you bump into a break tutorial
look what others you know series they
have on their youtube channel so simply
start doing lack of money is not an
excuse money helps but you don't have to
even have a
study you don't have to have extra money
to pay for the courses sure you have to
have the money to survive until you get
cetera but in order to learn damage yeah
a lot of open source project language
which are for free and a lot of groups
in code community that you can really
use if you want to learn coding you can
also go to the local meet them can also
visit local groups devoted to the given
language you can visit various forums
you can learn from YouTube tutorials
from blocks from medium articles so nice
to be learning to code I discovered that
majority of paid resources have tried
and before deciding on any faith course
you know that the servers you know how
it will work but also if you don't have
enough money to pay for it this tutorial
that they give can also give you the
basic knowledge that you need you need
file from every from each service still
you gain a lot of free material so
learning to come you don t spend a
fortune
good day it's Wednesday and my article
about my first stop that I took to let
while learning to code has been just
published it already has 150 uploads and
line comments so it means that on
average more than 10 people like this
article per hour I will provide the link
to this article below in the video
description so if you are interested
have a look there as I told you you can
really learn for free recently I bumped
into flexbox I go on git er so if you
have eyes open they're ready and love a
lot of pillow clear resources that there
are really over great quality you have
to have just only your eyes opened and
and look around what's possible and
remember that Google is your friend try
to move the first time with text box i
will start with navigation
Oh
[Music]
I
[Music]
this is the final version of my
education that I was working on Thanks
books it's like an example to have a bit
of practice for flex with navigation
it's pretty responsive it changes
according to the width of the viewport
[Music]
I've just invented the pricing list with
flexbox it just the desktop right now
but spice immunised this build with
black spots and whips us it's one of my
first synthetic red curry sauce and
because being there used to like your
CSS your hand goes to send powers and
placards hopefully we can get a compiled
version 2 can use under the bed scoffs
and compare CSS in order to confer or
you're checking the babies in place and
compile or that we may break through
especially if you try sauce for the
first time and i also used flexbox 04
despising this it looks like that
[Music]
that I've implemented with this effects
button SAS it this single molecule forum
where you can choose member columns they
eat then to how many people were with
the room it's like you know simple code
snippet super code snippet that may be
used for booking their rooms that like
conference rooms in a companion or
something similar and is it's a sphere
some simple wrapping the queries and
also amusing flat spots let's revise
flags box I got a box here and I will
try to revise what I learned with it is
in this box imagine this is the
container this is the diff dad's got a
display flash this is the nerve coming
at the slave flash we treat it as a
parent this is flex row when you change
it to flex column so when you go to
direction column they will be squeezed
this way by default they do not wrap by
default the energy not the elements do
not wrap so imagine we have more of the
elements the simplest option is to say
rah and these two extra elements then
we'll be right by default to the next
line the default order is zero so
whenever we change the order of an item
so whenever it for example this item
number one and we'll change the order to
one and by default all of the metal have
zero it will move here right out 001 so
setting x 2 minus 1 we move it to the
beginning it's pretty useful for a
responsive layouts for example when we
talk about having the order different on
mobile and the friend on desktop free
elements and they will be justified
center there will be saintly in the
center when we talk about justify
content we can also go to flex stardom
flags and by flex start it means that
all of the items will be moved to flags
start its legs Direction row so flex
started here another justified content
is flexed and as a result all of the
items will go to flex and because this
is flex Direction row and this is the
end it's good to remember when you get
lost where is the main axis so when is a
row is this way so it's a
horizontal line and when it's the column
when it comes to thank direction it's
from top to bottom have a look at the
description of this video below because
you will find out a lot of useful links
in order to learn and practice next
books it's funny evening and sleep this
article was also a huge circle
motivation for me thanks to Christine is
also available like that in Chinese you
will find the right she'll follow this
link I got a lot of feedback connected
with the article that I wrote and being
able to hear so many voices on and might
have so far and what could be done
differently and what's inspiring for
them but it was something that made my
week this week I've also got our 12
brownie points for helping other people
on get er and I gotta currently 477
brownie points so I'm missing 23 to my
500 points challenge in order to start
next level in fickle town one of the
biggest problems that I met this week
was nothing in fact smoke so because
going into levels of nesting and
sometimes can then gets tricky and you
have to be really careful with that next
week I want to work more with flex cuffs
and sauce so I want to do some more you
ilmn so we are using them and I want
also recovered this grid system because
flexbox as Iran's it's like pretty well
for smaller components but not necessary
for you know huge up layout and it seems
to be pretty fun later to build ah the
app and justice in flag stocks and
resist them and
by the framework because it's like
another level for me keep on doing stay
motivated and see you next week
Oh